what are the one or two things that are
necessary um
for a software platform to succeed at
scale and you mentioned speed but what
are some of the qualities that are
necessary
um for
one of these platforms to win
you know what in the end of the day what
determines the platform's success and
value is adoption rate and acceleration
of adoption and the only way that occurs
is that they have done some uh
development that solves an economic
problem i always say this about digital
currencies and digital platforms
what problem are you solving
in what way are you enhancing
a transaction or a problem that already
exists are you reducing friction in
financial markets are you accelerating
transactions or accuracy or
authenticating them what are you doing
that adds economic value so i would
argue long-term coins that have no
economic value are that because they
don't solve anything they don't act they
don't create any value anywhere and so
i'm very skeptical
of you know meme coins and long-term and
look nothing wrong with trading that's a
lot of fun but when you talk about
developing
um and you're sitting around thinking
about what problem are you solving
that's where the economic value is so
adoption rates and the reason ethereum
is so large now is because it was first
that it was widely adopted now because
some of its shortcomings are being
noticed by certain sectors of the
economy these other teams the polygon
teams of solona teams and and others are
saying well it's not good enough for
what we're doing and we're going to make
some changes here and that that is very
much worth investing in i'm excited to
have tiege hanley as the sponsor of
today's video they've helped me start
and maintain my skin care routine by
making the entire process uncomplicated
it's the best skin care system for guys
like you and me i recommend you start
with their level 1 system which comes
with all the basics a daily face wash to
get rid of the dirt and the grime on
your skin
a two times a week per exfoliating scrub
to get rid of dead skin cells you want
to look alive right an am moisturizer
with 20 spf because you should always
protect your skin from the sun i live in
miami i use that product all the time
and a pm moisturizer to help your skin
stay hydrated and healthy throughout the
night
my favorite part about teach hanley is
that every box comes with an instruction
card that tells you when to use each
product how much to use and in what
order
they really make the process of
achieving and maintaining amazing skin
really easy i've been using their
products for a little while now and i'm
hooked i might sound weird i'm trying to
protect my skin i look forward to my
morning and evening routines because i
just feel amazing and more confident
after using their products and i really
don't want any sun damage so that spf 20
is great in addition to amazing skin
members of the tees hanley get tons of
benefits including at least 20 off on
the retail price the ability to
customize your box pause or cancel at
any time and free us shipping and
because tiege hanley is sponsoring
today's video they're offering my
viewers a great deal just click the link
in the description and not only will you
get teach handling for the best possible
price but they'll also give you a free
gift with your first box
click that link and get started today
for just 30 dollars take care of
yourself and your skin there's a reason
they call me mr wonderful i look
wonderful
how do you define an asset bubble and do
you think that we are in one right now
when it comes to crypto
you know i i that's a great question and
and i
and i've watched uh bubbles grow and
pop and everything else
the thing to realize is
the market is the market
no one person can manipulate it even
though people claim they can it's
millions of decisions being made every
second in terms of what something is
worth
and it applies to every market whether
it's tulips or watches or bitcoin or
real estate
or gold it's the same dynamics when you
have a large participation in the asset
class and millions of people buy and
sell it the only thing i trust
is the market price because
you can't say it's overvalued or
undervalued the market determines that
for you you can make a long-term bet
that it will appreciate over time for
various reasons
but when you start to say something is a
bubble you're effectively saying you're
going to do some market timing that you
know something that everybody else
doesn't know
and once in a while you can be right but
over the long run
it's a fool's game and you can't win and
so my attitude about this is allocation
and diversification
so if you tell me that bitcoin is in a
bubble and overvalued you may be right
but it doesn't really matter to me in
terms of allocating to bitcoin it's
going to be allocated to because it is
an asset that millions of people own and
its market price is being determined by
the second 24 hours a day i happen to
think it's an asset not a currency
i like the software development
underneath it i think all the issues
around esd are going to get solved in
the next couple of years and it's going
to be more efficiently mined
but
i love the market being the market so
you know that's a really long answer to
say you can't know when when it's a
bubble you simply can't and if you think
you
yeah if you think you do you're
absolutely wrong
yeah that's fine i i asked that question
i see some people ask that and i realize
everyone has a different definition of
bubble so unless you like you define
what you mean by that uh the answer
won't mean anything you talk about asset
diversification and strategy and um a
lot of people especially um investors
that have held for a year two years plus
i've seen
the allocation in the portfolios grow to
much higher levels than where they
started um do you have any thoughts on
how people should they rebalance um
out of crypto into stocks or should they
try to rebalance some of their crypto
from
um like more edge assets to to large cap
assets or what um what what are some
strategies or or thoughts that you've
had um as your holdings have just
appreciated in value
that's a great question i get it all the
time and my answer is always the same
it's a binary decision first of all to
own crypto or not many people are
skeptical about it they're still not on
board their answer is no and they don't
have any allocation problems for those
of us have changed our minds and i'm one
of those constituencies i have decided
that this is a real asset class that the
software development has economic
meaning and i should be an investor in
it so
diversification is my number two issue
now in the in the stock world in the
bond world and the these assets that
have been around for hundreds of years i
have very simple rules that mandate how
i own them i never let one stock become
more than five percent waiting in any
portfolio and i never let a sector of
which there are eleven sectors in the s
p ever become more than 20
and so i am using the same rules now
that i use then on crypto so instead of
you know people say why don't you just
own bitcoin ethereum that's all you have
to do everything's correlated to the
price of those i don't believe that to
be true first of all and there's many
other economic applications or
software's or level one level two
blockchains that are very interesting to
me that have nothing to do with bitcoin
that i want to invest in so
what i'm trying to do is build a
portfolio it
at some point might get to 20
of my operating company right now it's
just over 10 about 10 and a half percent
but within that portfolio there's no one
token coin or chain that's more than 5
of that portfolio and so yes i am
actively
um adding and trimming based on
volatility and we've had lots of that in
the last couple of weeks and secondly
i'm doing a lot of staking
most of my positions are now being
staked
and
i use the ftx platform for that
and i also hold a significant material
position in usdc because i am now
starting to pay for assets in usdc and
be paid for assets in usdc so it's
become another currency in my portfolio
and i staked that as well and i'm
working with circle on that um it was
one of the very first corporate accounts
open there and i'm doing a lot of work
with my regulators and with my
accountants who have to sign next you
know sign my external um
quarterly reports and so you know one of
the things people forget is crypto so
niacin including all these other tokens
that um
you have a lot of work ahead of you in
terms of being uh compliant and i've
certainly uh lived through that in the
last six months yeah it's funny i was i
was actually talking with with jeremy at
salt back in back in september and he's
as we speak i i think he's right now
being grilled by congress um about about
regulation so i was going to ask you
about about stable coins and and your
thought on their potential utility
and uh
and also like if they're going to be
able to sort of withstand all this
regulatory backlash that they seem to be
receiving right now
i'm glad uh jeremy is taking this uh
bull by the horns and and wanting to be
part of creating policy for stable coins
they are here to stay um i remember when
i first bought my first usdc i think he
had 2 billion under management or
issued and now it's over 30. so it's
been adopted
widely by lots of of uh corporate
entities as well but i would prefer that
it be regulated i would prefer that the
rules uh be set by the regulator so that
i can increase my exposure to it and
frankly and i'm not speaking on his
behalf i'm just speculating if he had to
become a bank regulated like other banks
he would probably do that and and that
would be fine with me too you know i
think he's actually applied for for a
banking charter
he has he has and so that's an
indication from external viewers and you
know i and i'm also
just to be forthright and transparent
i'm a participant in the pipe should he
finish his transaction with a spat to go
public i'll be an investor in that pipe
and so
you know for me i've already uh decided
that the stablecoin i'm going to use is
usdc i'm very
comfortable with it i do not want to own
any asset and i don't that the sec is
investigating or litigating i want
nothing to do with that i am not a
crypto cowboy
how do you i mean yes you see i'm
curious you mentioned that because they
won't disclose what they're
investigating usually so how do you uh i
mean some of them
the ones that they are and have
disclosed um
yes exactly it's widely known and so the
minute that that information gets out i
want nothing to do with it and if i had
a position i would sell it
i have no interest in going into
conflict with regulators over my crypto
portfolio i want to be 100 compliant i
that's my mantra every day and that's
because i want to play in the
institutional market i'm not interested
in being you know some guy sitting in a
desk with his iphone trading bitcoin
that's not what i do and so um
this is the beginning of a very long
process by which the regulator will set
rules because everybody knows this asset
class is not going away
so i mean one of the reasons that a lot
of people know you honestly the first
time i first heard your name years ago
was was from shark tank and and sort of
the
like taking the vc approach to to
investing and uh with some of the long
time horizons that uh certain people
purchase coins hoping that they'll pay
off in five seven ten years from now
i'm interested if in you putting on sort
of your vc hat and thinking about how
you approach the space from from from
that point of view
yeah i mean that's a great question
because that's how i'm approaching the
space i i have uh made investments in
nascent tokens very early in their
development
same with level one level two chain
companies um
i i basically
i look at the landscape i keep my you
know i'm pretty wired into the community
now which is great and so when i hear of
a new uh team a new a new idea
i'm very fortunate i simply call them up
and either do a zoom call with them or
physically meet with them if i'm going
to be in that country
and
sometimes i acquire a control position
sometimes i just take a shareholding
position sometimes i buy them with one
of my public companies and i'm an
investor in i do all of the above and
but i go back to the idea that this is
no different than when i was at the
learning company looking at teams that
were building educational software or
gaming software it it's there's no
difference at all to me so you know i've
been doing this for 35 years and
crypto is no different and it's a very
comfortable space to be in for me i mean
i just
i just consider it software development
and and all of the other um
you know
whatever you want to call it social
media hype and and all the
the blogs that you know this dogecoin
over bitcoin and yadda yadda it's all
irrelevant to me what matters to me is
what's the software do what problem does
it solve where's the economic value and
who's maintaining the code that's how i
look at it there are a couple of the
biggest misconceptions about crypto that
you find yourself having to to refute
when you talk to friends or family and
and they they look at you side eyes when
you when you talk about crypto
yeah um there's there's you know the
different cryptos have different issues
dogecoin is a meme coin uh potherium
which is uh gives
which is a coin for you know dogecoins
for dogs potheriums for cats patherium
gives to animal shelters i mean these
are meme coins and so
they represent communities and people
that have a an interest and so
when people are skeptical about them i
say look they have a following because
people believe in their mission and who
are you to refute it now when it comes
to bitcoin there's many issues that uh
that i get cornered on a lot the largest
is esg
uh people are very unhappy with the way
china made bitcoin you know in past
years by burning coal and making
electricity and obviously there's a lot
of controversy about that and
here in the u.s we are looking for ways
to to mine bitcoin and be awarded coins
on an ethical and esg basis i always go
back to the same answer when people are
so skeptical
i say it's the market being the market
and who are you
to tell the market what to do you can be
a participant in the market but you in
no way can control it and you know
that is the best way to look at
cryptocurrencies and crypto assets and
blockchain in itself
um because this is december 2022 i have
to ask you a question about nfts and the
metaverse so uh two-part question um
generally what are what are your
thoughts on um on this i guess
relatively new vertical yeah look i
think nfts are going to be um
bigger than bitcoin because they offer
so much value around authentication
and inventory management and all kinds
of use cases in different asset classes
i prefer nfts tied to
hard assets physical assets the one that
i'm working on developing a white paper
for is the watch industry i've invested
in that because we have so much fraud in
watch collecting and we can eliminate
that fraud using some very high
resolution scanning of dials
linked to nfts on the smart chain so
that the watchmaker can identify what
they made when they made it and who owns
it and when it transacts in the open
market and when it's stolen as well so i
think that's a very big market and
towards investing in that space i made a
material investment in immutable
holdings um
jordan freed's company who is uh who
owns nft.com which he's launching in
january as well as wonderfuy uh which is
um a company that's consolidating assets
in the crypto space
and
they're both large positions for me and
i like the management teams but they are
focusing on creating value around the
nft market curating them
creating them managing them and there's
a lot of work going on in making these
ubiquitous and very liquid so that you
know
that an nft can trade on any blockchain
whether it's solana or ethereum or hbar
or whatever
these assets are going to be very big
and i think next year
2022 is going to be the year of the nft
and actually just leads me to my last
question i wanted to know if you had any
big predictions for 2022
it's nfts i think you're going to see
such remarkable software development and
momentum in so many different asset
classes uh it's going to dominate the
headlines in the crypto space
cav loves watches who knew yes i love
watches kevin kev love watches so we're
comparing the hardware what do you love
kev uh i am a ap guy at heart uh adimar
pk yes royal okay yes i'm a very i'm i'm
very much well dedicated to the royal
alert the term space uh i'm a sucker for
craftsmanship
that's what he yes yes sucker for
craftsmanship more importantly the
open-faced world of watches i love to
see the story behind what are you
featuring right now well this is a
skeleton this is a sm
that is so hot it's a platinum
you know that's what he said yes yes
sucker for craftsmanship more
importantly the open face world of
watches i love to see the story behind
what are you featuring right now well
this is a skeleton this is
that is so hot it's a platinum platinum
royal oak skeleton uh one out of 150 i
believe there's only 150 of these pieces
made this boy knows how to buy watches
because when there's only 150 the price
goes it goes up that's right you're
making money that's right absolutely and
you bought it at retail absolutely no no
you have to be able to make smart
purchases and uh because of myself and
my relationships with these brands i'm
able to get in at cost and not uh go to
the secondary market and have the whole
so a watch like this is up almost 100
percent that's why absolutely the key is
to really develop your brand with the
watchmakers because they want to give
you retail prices absolutely that works
but that's a heck of a piece that's a
skeleton really really hard to get and
probably if you wanted to buy it it
would be very expensive today yes today
it's extremely expensive which is why
it's good to have great partners shouts
out to my team at ap francois i love you
thank you for always making me happy oh
you're really sucking up the francoise
that's no question
where is my one-of-a-kind shark tank ap
skeleton i'm still waiting for it it's
coming it's been two years well hey look
i don't know what that is but i do know
they give me mine on time all right wow
ain't that outrageous but just while
we're at it here let's talk this little
piece
eye of the tiger today i have the tiger
so you know let's just touch those faces
shazam that's what happened value was
created there i love that
on the shark tank see you next time if
you like that video wait did you see my
next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe